voir des images je vous dis que vous
ramène du goût qui sont vraiment qu'ils
vont vraiment je vous dis vous vous
retournez un petit peu voilà tous ceux
qui sont avec nous on voulait absolument
nous - la production pure go viennent
nous voir ce soit parce que on a besoin
d aide hugo tu vas nous expliquer
pourquoi tu es là tu vas nous parle et a
mis en ligne le 10 mai un reportage sur
combiné points comme tu nous parlais du
tt au kasaï république démocratique du
congo avec casas exactement plusieurs
millions de personnes souffrent
d'insécurité alimentaire extrême et
d'exactions donc meurtrière quatre cent
mille enfants risquent de mourir de faim
dans les prochains mois si rien n'est
fait alors on a on a des images vous
résumer parfaitement cette situation
au début de votre reportage je reproche
que je propose on les regarde et après
vous allez nous dire ce que vous avez
amené quelque chose de très important et
on a un message à faire passer
regardez ces images vraiment c'est un
moment important dans tp c'est quelque
chose qu'on voulait absolument faire ce
soir avec le corps garde sommes à
tshikapa dans la région du kassaï en
république démocratique du congo
c'est un drame silencieux au kasaï la
mort menace des familles entières dans
la brousse où les habitants se sont
réfugiés pendant les combats
mais aussi dans les villages isolés que
les humanitaires peinent à atteindre à
cause de l'état des routes thonaille
tenez à locaux dynamique et abolit la
naïve et anna alors il ya d'autres
images la famine et est très élevé dans
cette région vous avez tenté de le
montrer au travers des images très
choquante qui font prendre conscience de
la gravité je vous le dis de la
situation on assiste par exemple à la
pesée d'un enfant de trois ans ouais et
ça ça c'est une image folle regarder
là c'est un des très nombreux centres de
santé de la région gérée par action
contre la faim
c'est là que sont amenés les enfants qui
souffrent de malnutrition combien de
personnes vous recevez dans ce centre à
peu près tous les jours aux fêtes et
tous les jours nous avons une moyenne de
80 malades s'est apaisée witkin 8,9
sanglant et il a quel âge l'enfant
atteint 6 mois 3 ans
alors hugo on va montrer d'autres images
dans un instant que nous avons donnée
donc combiner vous aviez un message à
faire passer ce soir important à tous
les gens qui nous regardent juste
peut-être expliquer en 30 secondes les
raisons de cette famine basique en fait
c'est une région le kasaï où il ya eu
une guerre civile en 2016 entre une
milice et l'armée les combats ont eu
lieu dans les villages ce qui a poussé
la population à fuir dans la brousse
abandonner leurs champs abandonnés leurs
récoltes et pendant plusieurs mois voire
plusieurs années les enfants les
familles ont mangé ce qu'ils trouvaient
dans la brousse des feuilles de manioc
un peu d'eau et donc c'est pour ça
qu'ils sont tombés en état de
malnutrition c'est pour ça qu'il ya
quatre cent mille enfants qui risquent
de mourir dans les mois qui viennent si
rien n'est fait et on s'est dit qu'on
pouvait pas revenir d'un reportage comme
ça qui nous a bouleversés qui nous a
vraiment touché 500 faire quelque chose
sans proposer aux gens qui regardent
leurs portages d'agir derrière pour
essayer de sauver ces enfants et
d'améliorer la situation et c'est pour
ça qu'on a décidé avec combiné de lancer
une levée de fonds qui va aller à action
contre la faim qui est une association
française qui est présente dans le kasaï
pour aider à cette association à nourrir
ses enfants elle est soignée à
distribuer de la nourriture
alors vous allez voir ça va ça va
s'afficher au bas de l'écran donc
l'adresse pour participer là vous avez
déjà récolté 143 milles euros sur un
objectif de 200 mille euros
sachez qu'aujourd'hui voilà nous en tout
cas on voulait aussi vous faire un don
de 10 mille euros voilà pour faire
avancer les choses mais pour parce qu'on
n'y a pas de raison qu'on demande bien
sûr et vraiment je vous dis je
les centres de soins donc sont
surchargés dépasser non pas disposition
tous les moyens nécessaires bien sûr
pour soigner correctement les plus
jeunes vous le montre également
il arrive donc souvent de perdre des
enfants regardent voilà c'est une petite
fille qui a deux ans et demi qui pèse à
peine 6 kg et qui est très faible a
notamment beaucoup de fièvre et problème
c'est que les enfant malnutri on peut
pas leur donner de médicaments pour
faire baisser la fièvre parce qu'ils ont
déjà les reins très affaibli donc
on peut juste leur mettre un petit peu
d'eau froide sur la tête est-ce que vous
avez déjà perdu des enfants ici nous
avons déjà porté normande déjà compté
700 témoins de l'année passée voilà on
voulait absolument vous montrer ces
images ce soir à ce reportage de
combinés c'est vrai qu'on est une
émission de divertissement on parle de
tout me trouve autour montré est
vraiment hugo ou voulait faire passer
aussi un message qu'ils avaient amené un
petit sachet qui est important ouais
parce que ce qui est vraiment important
à dire aux gens qui regardent c'est que
même avec un don de 5 euros on peut
faire changer les choses et on peut
participer à améliorer la vie de ses
enfants
ça c'est ce qu'on appelle un plein qui
note c'est une ration nutritionnelle
d'urgence à base de pâte d'arachide et
c'est ça que les médecins les
humanitaires d'action contre la faim de
nos enfants qui sont vraiment dans un
état très grave et ça ça leur permet
petit à petit de sortir de l'urgence et
qu'ils en espérant sauver leur vie et ce
à une ration comme ça ça coûte 25
centimes donc si vous donnez 5 euros
action contre la faim peut acheter 20
races mans comme ça avec 20 ration comme
ça à un enfant qui est dans un état très
grave
il peut manger pendant 20 jours s'il y
en a un par jour à peu près pour des
enfants qui sont vraiment très
malnutries donc même avec 5 euros je
sais que c'est très difficile de donner
de l'argent aujourd'hui surtout pour les
jeunes mais avec 5 euros on peut
vraiment participé à sauver concrètement
ces enfants avec 50 euros on finance le
traitement complet qui va permettre de
sauver un enfant qui en état de
malnutrition sévère aiguë donc c'est du
tout c'est du concret le don merci hugo
j'aurais vous remercier d'être de nous
voir parce que hugo il va il va au bout
de ses trucs et je sais que à chaque
fois que fait des reportages tu reviens
et essaie de faire avancer les choses
et là c'est encore ce que tu as fait
vous dire bravo pour ce que tu fais
mais absolument qui viennent que toi et
ton bien noire continue pour d'autres
causes comme ça vraiment je serai
présent a pourtant connu pour montrer
ces images
hugo donc voilà vous pouvez retrouvez
moi je les ai vus j'ai totalement
bouleversé et vaillamment
je rappelle simplement pour tout le
monde sache c'était l'ancien zaïre 1
c'est ça il ya eu quand même des
dictateurs enfin comment dirais-je le
président mobutu d'abord un ordinateur
oui on peut le dire mobutu maintenant
kabila et c'est vrai que c'est très dur
ce qui se passe ça fait des années
qu'ils sont en guerre ça fait des années
qu'ils ne mangent pas ça fait des années
et si nous on n'intervient pas tous ces
gens vont mourir comme vous le dites
bien de votre reportage et le problème
surtout c'est que les crises
humanitaires quand personne n'en parle
ce qui est le cas pour ce qui se passe
au cassé aujourd'hui personne ne donne
d'argent on parle beaucoup de la syrie
beaucoup de y ait beaucoup de vies
humaines c'est aussi grave ce qui se
passe au kasaï et personne n'en parle en
parler c'est participer à l'eso et aussi
merci